[Musique]
ainsi donc vous réunissez tous les arts
tous les dons de plaire pompadour vous
embellissez la cour le parnasse et
cythère charme de tous les yeux trésor
d'un seul mort tels que votre amour soit
éternelle que tous vos jours soit
marquée par des fêtes que de nouveaux
succès marque ceux de louis vivaient
tous deux cents et demi et garder tous
deux vos conquêtes
ces quelques vers de voltaire qui chante
les louanges de madame de pompadour
séduisirent la marquise on l'accusa
pourtant l'auteur de comparer
l'incomparable les conquêtes guerrières
de louis 15 à celle du coeur de sa
maîtresse le voeu formulé par voltaire
pour la constance perpétuelle des deux
amants indigne à la cour et provoque
kaas à 2010 grâce
une diseuse de bonne aventure avait
pourtant prédit la destinée
extraordinaire de cette roturière à
l'exquise beauté et du quai sous la
protection des frères paris ce puissant
financier de l'époque pour devenir la
brillante favorite du roi
surnommé l'oracle de la cour
cette quasi reine de france et l'ombre
politique de louis 15 véritable ministre
de la nuit dans la moiteur des alcôves
elle chuchote à l'oreille du roi et
modifient bien des destins madame de
pompadour a été pour loïc 15 j'allais
dire son éminence rose en quelque sorte
parce que d'abord sa psychologue ou sa
psychothérapeute parce que louis 15
était quelqu'un de dépressif madame de
pompadour va être une des maîtresses en
titre les plus importantes de l'histoire
de france
elle va rester dix neuf années à la cour
oui 15 roi quelque peu éclipsé par
l'histoire entre l'absolutisme du roi
soleil et le raz de marée de la
révolution française voit éclore au
cours d'un règne long de 59 ans
l'étincelante pensée des lumières
il hérite d'un royaume puissant mais
ruiné par les guerres incessantes de
louis xiv lé tentative risquée du régent
philippe 2 pour sauver l'économie
française dans ce xviiie siècle synonyme
de changement social profond la
sauvegarde de la monarchie absolue va se
révéler bien au delà des capacités de
louis 15 et ses échecs politiques vont
précipiter le déclin de la royauté
le parfum de la pompadour et partout
dans les grandes comme dans les petites
affaires du royaume elle gouverne
d'instinct plus que de raison et
n'hésite pas à conspirer pour son roi
bien-aimé renversant les alliances et
bousculant ainsi le paysage de la
diplomatie européenne
durant vingt ans elle demeure la menthe
puis l'ami essentiel de louis 15 et aux
yeux de l'histoire
la dernière grande favorite au royal
jamais une femme n'a autant susciter de
sentiments contradictoires objet de
désir ou de calomnies favorite décrié
dans de violents pamphlet la vie de la
marquise de pompadour à alimenter des
siècles de fantasmes
[Musique]
louis xiv arrière grand père et
prédécesseur de louis 15 règne 72 ans
sur la france plus longtemps qu'aucun
autre monarque de l'histoire sous
l'autorité absolue du roi soleil
la france devient l'un des pays les plus
puissants d'europe est une référence
suprême dans le domaine artistique louis
xiv se vendent être le premier roi de
france à connaître ses arrière petits
fils tout en étant encore en bonne santé
il est alors persuadé que c'est
génération d'héritiers vont assurer sans
mal la pérennité de la lignée des
bourbeau pourtant durant les dernières
années de son règne un funeste destin
s'abat sur la famille royale et met en
péril la succession au trône de france
en 1711 louis xiv est un vieux monsieur
mais qui règne encore il a encore quatre
ans devant lui et il a un fils qui peut
le remplacer qu'il ya une cinquantaine
d'années
c'est le grand dauphin et oui mais le
grand dauphin meurt en 1711 donc plus
d'espoir de ce côté là dieu soit loué le
grand dauphin avait lui même un fils
surnommait le dauphin qui est
susceptible de d'hériter la couronne
non il n'en est pas question non plus
parce qu en 1712 c'est à dire l'année
suivante le dauphin lui-même meurt alors
que va-t-il se passer
eh bien le dauphin avait dieu merci deux
fils oui mais parmi ses fils y en a un
autre qui meurt en 1714
il n'en reste qu'un tout petit petit ya
cinq ans en 1715
ce sera notre futur louis 15
à la mort de louis xiv en 1715 le destin
du royaume est lié à la survie de son
fragile arrière petit fils alors âgé de
5 ans l'enfant survit miraculeusement
grâce aux soins attentifs de sa
gouvernante madame de ventadour qui
interdit aux médecins de l'approcher et
préfère le soigner elle même
[Musique]
alors on connaît la scène quand louis
xiv et sur son lit d'agonie
il fait venir le seul héritier de la
couronne qui lui reste c'est à dire son
arrière petit fils qui va devenir louis
15 d'une seconde à l'autre et il lui dit
j'ai trop aimé la guerre en cela ne me
mettais jamais et en effet il a aimé la
guerre à tel point que les caisses de la
france aux archives ina le royaume est
dans un état de misère terrible louis
xiv lègue à son successeur en royaumes
puissant redouté de ses voisins mais
aussi épuisé par un demi siècle de
guerres incessantes et d'imposer
écrasant une france accablé par la
pauvreté
la france du xviiie siècle connaît alors
des changements radicaux
après plusieurs décennies de répression
les idées progressistes se développe au
cours de ce qu'on appellera plus tard le
siècle des lumières des critiques
s'élèvent pour dénoncer les inégalités
et réclament une réforme fiscale
l'autorité royale est remise en question
[Musique]
louis 15 le bel enfant roi cristallise
tous les espoirs lorsqu'il accède au
trône en 1715 la population a soif de
nouveauté et le petit prince bourbon à
une allure majestueuse
la tradition exige qu'une ré gens se
soient mises en place jusqu'à la
majorité du souverain fixé à 13 ans
philippe d'orléans neveu de louis xiv
devient donc régent et va gouverner la
france 2007 115 à 10 723 en tant que
libéral il est favorable à un équilibre
des pouvoirs et redonne aux parlements
régionaux
les prérogatives que louis xiv leur
avait enlevé les efforts du régent vers
une modernisation du système financier
donnent leurs premiers résultats
mais les audaces de son conseiller
l'économiste john law provoque une
terrible banqueroute
le 25 octobre 10 722 louis caset sacrés
à reims et atteint sa majorité quatre
mois plus tard en février 10 723 c'est
la fin de la régence surnommé de bien
aimer il jouit d'une excellente image au
début de son règne
les premières années du règne de louis
15 sont sont florissantes et on l'a
précis c'est là où ils méritent
précisément ce surnom justifier de bien
aimer c'est un c'est un jeune roi qui
veut essayer d'éviter la guerre autant
qu'il est possible parce que il suit en
cela le conseil de son arrière grand
père agonisant et la france marouane le
sang sans pas si mal le roi a choisi de
confier les rênes du pouvoir
un principal ministre à louis iv henri
de bourbon condé disgracieux en 1726 oui
15 appelle alors à ses côtés son ancien
précepteur le cardinal de fleury
ce dernier ouvre la période la plus
prospère du règne il va rester au
pouvoir pendant 17 ans
il parvient à éviter la guerre à
l'exception d'un conflit pour la
succession de pologne 17 133,38 qui va
aboutir à l'acquisition de la précieuse
province de lorraine pendant les
premières années de son règne
louis 15 est bien perçu par ce que il
incarne l'espoir l'espérance la fin d'un
certain despotisme le 5 septembre 10 725
malgré les protestations de la cour qui
parle de mésalliance le roy épouse marie
lessines ce cas la fille du roi détrôné
de pologne de sept ans son aîné
marie donne à son époux dix enfants en
dix ans
trois filles naissent avant le premier
garçon le dauphin louis ferdinand qui
voit le jour en 1729
la popularité de louis 15 grandi il est
reconnaissant à son épouse de lui avoir
donné ses enfants et ils forment pendant
plusieurs années un couple très heureux
quand il était enfant louis 15 était un
petit garçon timide extrêmement timide
il était d'ailleurs caché derrière le
cardinal fleuri au fur et à mesure du
temps et surtout de par son mariage avec
marie l'exarchat il va découvrir les
plaisirs de la vie et à partir de ce
moment là il va se libérer complètement
on dit d'ailleurs avec beaucoup de
beaucoup de plaisanteries que louis casa
honorer cette fois marc il exerce cas
lors de la première nuit et que c'est à
partir de ce moment là qu'il va prendre
de l'assurance
c'est un peu exagéré louisiens et fidèle
marie leczinska pendant une dizaine
d'années il fait d'ailleurs une dizaine
d'enfants
j'étais un jour marie leczinska n'en
pouvant plus lui dit on le sait toujours
grosse toujours couchée toujours à
coucher c'est fini on peut dormir
ensemble mais on ne couche plus ensemble
mais louis 15 qui était d'une complexion
amoureuse assez assez brillante le dit
mais alors qu'est ce que je vais devenir
ob vous vivez votre vie savais
absolument égal donc louis 15 à vivre sa
vie va commencer à voir une belle
tribune petite maîtresse notamment la
pucelle qui deviendra la plus célèbre
c'est jeanne antoinette poisson la
célèbre madame de pompadour
naturellement
le nom de madame de pompadour demeure
intimement lié à celui du roi louis 15
la vie étonnante est l'extraordinaire
ascension vers le pouvoir de cette femme
de thé d'esprit de grâce et d'une
sublime beauté en ont fait une véritable
légende jeanne antoinette poisson n'est
à paris le 29 décembre 10 721 elle est
la fille aînée de françois poisson
écuyers de son altesse royale qui a
débuté comme transporteur de vivre dans
l'armée et de louise madeleine de la
motte la famille poisson appartient à la
bourgeoisie mais jouit des avantages que
lui procure des amis haut placés
[Musique]
alors monsieur poisson lui il est
contraint à l'exil suite d'une affaire
de fournitures aux armées qui tourne mal
et puis la jeune jeanne poisson reste
avec sa mère et sa mère de riches
protecteur et ses protecteurs s'occupe
de l'éducation de jeunes poissons veille
à ce qu'elle fréquente les salons
qu'elle est de la conversation beaucoup
de charme elle est assez jolie jane
entrenait de poisson est une petite
bourgeoise elle a un père financier
escroc si au passage qui va d'ailleurs
devoir fuir la france et les autorités
et donc la mère de jeanne antoinette est
obligé pour pouvoir vivre de prendre un
amant elle va prendre charles normand de
tournon m
et c'est ce monsieur qui va présenter à
jeanne antoinette poisson son futur mari
monsieur d'etiolles
le normand de tournai m ami des frères
parisse et financier influent de
l'époque et le bienfaiteur qui offre à
jeanne antoinette une éducation de
princesse et la marie à son neveu
charles lenormand d'etiolles en 1741 la
jeune femme fréquente bientôt les
cercles intellectuels parisiens les
parisse perçoivent rapidement dans cette
région nantes beauté un moyen de
s'approcher des faveurs royal
après sept ans de mariage l'intérêt de
louis 15 pour son épouse
la mode est dévouée marie lésine ce cas
commencent à décliner
il jette alors successivement son dévolu
sur les trois soeurs de neil louis 15
avait fait appel à son ministre des
plaisirs comme il l'appelait qui lui
avait dit je connais une petite jeune
femme ou qui s'appelle louise louise
marie louise de magazine elle qui est
belle comme un coeur et qui s'étiole qui
s'ennuient vous pourriez peut-être aller
lui dire deux mots et en effet on l'a vu
dans les couloirs de versailles sont
allés nuitamment pour rejoindre la
petite louise de magazine elle qui a été
sa première maîtresse et comme il avait
l'esprit de famille louis 15 et bien
quand il en a eu assez de louise de
maddie il a pris sa soeur cadette et
ensuite sa soeur balsamine en la
personne de celle qu'il fera d'ailleurs
duchesse de châteauroux à la mort subite
de madame de châteauroux la place très
convoitée de favorites royales devient
l'enjeu des intrigues de la cour
c'est à ce moment là que jeanne
antoinette poisson fait son entrée dans
la société parisienne
ayant acquis les manières du monde elle
est dotée de tous les talents et les
grandes minces est lancé il possède une
démarche des plus gracieuse son visage
révèle anne ovale parfait
hélas les cheveux châtain clair son
sourire découvre d'impeccables dents
blanches et ses yeux sont dinguerie
persan madame d'etiolles car c'est son
nom maintenant fréquentent les fameux
salon parisien qui accorde aux femmes
une fonction culturelle importante elle
se conforme au mode de vie de la bonne
société et reçoit dans sa propriété
d'etiolles près de paris où elle donne
des représentations privé dans le petit
théâtre
kelly a fait construire cette propriété
se trouve justement tout près du château
de choisy que le roi acquiert peu de
temps auparavant il entend parler de la
ravissante madame d'etiolles et la
croiser au cours d'une chasse en forêt
de sénart elle était née poisson comme
son nom l'indiqué elle avait épousé
monsieur lenormand d'etiolles et elle
avait un petit château du côté de
choisy-le-roi où elle vivait avec son
mari et elle voyait régulièrement le roi
passé aller à la chasse
elle s'était dit un jour celui là je
l'aurais et madame de pompadour est une
très très très belle femme au tout début
de la rencontre qu'elle a avec louis 15
et elle va se faire repérer façon très
très très amusante elle va s'habiller de
rose quand son véhicule c'est son fait
et on est habillé de bleu et elle va
s'habiller de bleus quand son feuilleton
est habillé de rose et du coup oui 15 la
repère et lui envoie une invitation à un
bal masqué le fameux bal des ifs
alors tout le monde était déguisé en en
if et c'est certainement que ce soir là
que le mouchoir fut jetée que jeanne
antoinette poisson est devenue la
maîtresse de louis 15
lors du bal des ifs toutes les
attentions sont tournés vers cette
nouvelle conquête lumineuse qui danse
avec le roi
s'il voulait véritablement que madame de
pompadour deviennent maîtresse
officielle
il fallait la présenter alors il va
laisser passer l'été et en septembre
1745 et bien jeanne antoinette poisson
marquise de pompadour entre à la cour de
versailles après une romance est clair
label mondaine et itri marquise de
pompadour et présenté officiellement à
la cour le 14 septembre 1745
celle qui plaisantait en disant à son
mari je ne vous abandonnerai jamais sauf
naturellement pour le roi vient
d'accomplir cette prophétie la grande
noblesse est furieuse en plus d'être une
roturière
c'est un moins que rien appartient à la
caste de la richesse véreuses et des
fermiers généraux
madame de pompadour à versailles et
curieusement assez bien apprécié de de
la reine de marie leczinska parce
qu'elle sait ne pas et elle ne pas
s'étaler ne pas se montrer comme comme
dominante comme supérieur
madoré discrète elle est toute menue
toute fine et toute discrète et c'est
bien que la reine l'apprécié énormément
en revanche dans l'entourage du roi dans
toute l'aristocratie
on lui reproche évidemment de n'être
qu'une rupture hier de ne pas avoir sa
place à versailles mais néanmoins elle
la gardera pendant des dizaines d'années
madame de pompadour bri dans son rôle de
favorite
elle organise des guinéens formelle dans
ces petits appartements qu'on peut
encore admirer de nos jours au château
de versailles
juste au dessus du bureau et de la
chambre du roi
[Musique]
et
coût 15 d'un naturel dépressif trouve
dans les appartements privés de sa
maîtresse l'intimité et la présence
féminine rassurante recherché pendant si
longtemps
il avait des pressions considérables et
elle le soignait à sa manière c'est à
dire en organisant des soirées en jouant
des pièces de théâtre en lui faisant
faire la cuisine
et puis surtout en étant son ministre
des beaux-arts je crois que le véritable
premier ministre de la culture dans
l'histoire c'est madame de pompadour
la magnificence et la parade du grand
siècle de louis xiv ouvre une voie
royale à la grâce au charme et au
plaisir du xviiie siècle dans le sillage
des progrès scientifiques et techniques
le fameux siècle des lumières voit la
naissance d'une curiosité intellectuelle
inédite le véritable révolution des
idées ils traversent alors l'europe
préfigurant la révolution politique à
venir
madame de pompadour c'est une femme qui
a beaucoup beaucoup d'ouverture et c'est
finalement louis 15 rentrer tout
doucement dans la philosophie des
lumières si le siècle de louis xiv
rentrer tout doucement de la philosophie
des lumières on le doit en grande partie
à cette femme qui a permis l'évolution
des idées et qui a fait en sorte que
l'ensemble des artistes puissent
s'épanouir et dire sans véritablement se
cacher ce qu'ils pensent et ce mouvement
philosophie des lumières imagine
construire un monde meilleur fondé sur
un combat éclairée par la raison et la
diffusion du savoir pour tous contre les
ténèbres de l'ignorance et de la
tyrannie
écrasons l'infâme écrit voltaire en
désignant la superstition et le
fanatisme
cette philosophie entraîne une ligne
évitables remise en question de la
tradition et de l'autorité dont les
cibles principales sont l'église
catholique et la grande noblesse
héréditaire c'est l'époque des grands
philosophes que son compte est ce que
voltaire et rousseau
quelles que soient leurs opinions
politiques ils plaident tous pour la
liberté civile et de nombreux monarque
eux se sentent menacés par ces idées
nouvelles
voltaire transforme durablement le
climat intellectuel de l'époque
les partisans de la libre pensée la
tolérance religieuse de loi plus
clémente et de finances saines cet
humaniste fustige l'absurdité des
guerres contraint à l'exil à cause de
ses idées libérales
il se réfugie un temps à la cour du
grand roi philosophe frédéric ii de
prusse
il ouvre ainsi la voie à cette armée de
penseurs emmené par les encyclopédistes
qui reprendront le flambeau dans le
dernier quart du siècle
ces érudits font partie du mouvement
libéral favorable aux réformes qu'on
appelle partie philosophique en
opposition au parti des dévots qui
défend les intérêts de l'église
alors d'abord c'est souvent tôt qu'on
échange les les livres c'est sous le
manteau qu'on échange les idées les
petits billets et puis madame de
pompadour au passage va laisser faire
les choses et à permettre à ses artistes
et à ces écrivains de publier ses
nouvelles idées
il y à un bouillonnement des idées
auxquelles le roi ben l'euro est un peu
étranger parce que ça n'intéresse pas il
n'aime pas trop les querelles
strictement intellectuelle la recherche
du bonheur remplace peu à peu la quête
du salut à la lueur de la raison n'est
une démarche nouvelle de recherche de la
connaissance où il devient déterminant
de pouvoir analyser remettre en
questions examinées échanger des
hypothèses en toute liberté
alors on va également prêté à madame de
pompadour une image tout à fait réelle
c'est une femme qui aime les artistes
lm fragonard elle est bouché c'est une
femme qui va aider également les
écrivains de son temps les
encyclopédistes
diderot rousseau rousseau qui d'ailleurs
le la remerciera pas autant que ça
madame de pompadour est une libérale
elle soutient son ami voltaire les
encyclopédistes et denis diderot contre
les attaques de l'église
il faut savoir que c'était un petit peu
grâce à madame de pompadour que la
fameuse encyclopédie régler les
philosophes contestataires les écrivains
tels que voltaire tels que diderot tels
que rousseau tels que d'alembert vont
être autorisés à publier leurs écrits
parce que louis 15 voulait les censurer
à l'origine et madame de pompadour va
organiser des soirées dans lesquels avec
quelques amis et le roi elle jouera au
jeu des devinettes en disant qu'est ce
que c'est que cet instrument
les gens ne savent pas et bien il faut
aller le chercher dans l'encyclopédie et
on ouvre l encyclopédie et on est
émerveillé par tout ce que l'on
découvrait et louis 15 à 10 mais c'est
très beau on va éditer l'encyclopédie on
a mis en place en france un système de
pour apprendre aux français à lire et à
écrire on a beaucoup moins
d'analphabètes sous louis 15 qu'on en a
sous louis xiv en pourcentage et ce qui
est intéressant c'est que alors à partir
du moment où on sait lire on sait écrire
on sait aussi penser l'éducation est
érigée en principe fondamental des
lumières l'encyclopédie ou dictionnaire
raisonné des sciences des arts et des
métiers comprend 35 volumes illustrés
auquel ont participé près de 150 savants
et éminent spécialiste pendant 20 ans
diderot écrit que le but d'une
encyclopédie est de rassembler les
connaissances éparses sur la surface de
la terre temps d'exposer le système
général aux hommes avec qui nous vivons
et de le transmettre aux hommes qui
viendront après nous
afin que les travaux des siècles passés
n'est pas été inutile pour les siècles
qui succéderont que nous ne venons plus
instruits de vienne en même temps plus
vertueux et plus heureux et que nous ne
mesurions pas sans avoir bien méritée du
genre humain
finalement oui 15 et est un est un homme
très très sympathique même s'il n'est
pas d'accord finalement au bout du
compte il s'en moque un peu
c'est quelqu'un qu'il laisse faire et
c'est en ayant cette attitude que
finalement il va aussi déclenché cette
ce nombre de dcri qui vont qui vont être
publiés en france puisque madame de
pompadour n'aura aucun mal à faire
publier des écrits qui était avant tout
public en hollande pour éviter la
censure donc cette philosophie des
lumières va faire évoluer les idées
grande protectrice des arts
collectionneuse passionnée d'oeuvre de
mobilier précieux madame de pompadour
participe largement à développer la
culture de son époque
si le règne de louis 15 est souvent
considérée comme l'apogée de
l'architecturé française et des arts
décoratifs
c'est en grande partie grâce au mécénat
exercée par la marquise l'a fait bâtir
des quantités de monuments l'école
militaire
elle et occupe une place capitale dans
l'époque louis 15 et quand on parle du
style
loïc est à dire le style un peu rococo
et bien on devrais je crois
historiquement dire le style pompadour
le style associé à l'europe du xviiie
siècle est appelée rococo l'art en
postant évolution reflète les idées les
aspirations de son époque
ce nouveau courant reflète la réaction
aux règles rigides établi par louis xiv
auparavant l'académie royale contrôler
la vie artistique du pays
mais déjà la période de la régence
impulser un changement décisif le rococo
ressemble au théâtre baroque mais à une
échelle plus petite plus intime et plus
léger les paysages de la peinture de
genre deviennent à la mode et on voit
apparaître un courant de sensualité
raffinés parmi les premiers peintres de
ce style jugé décadent on trouve antoine
va tôt et françois boucher leur modèle
et le peintre flamand pierre paul rubens
en lequel il trouve tout ce que
l'académie désapprouvait couleurs
lumières mouvement est un plaisir
évident de la ville
antoine bateau est un grand coloriste
connu pour avoir créé un genre bien
personnelle qu'on appelle les fêtes
galantes
ce sont des scènes charmante idyllique
et bucolique baigné d'une atmosphère
théâtrale emprunté à la comédie
italienne
françois boucher a la chance d'être sous
la protection de l'illustre madame de
pompadour boucher et vato capte l'esprit
de la société parisienne où les nobles
se plaisent à jouer la comédie
comme si leur vie était aussi
insouciante que celle du berger et de la
bergère représentés dans les tableaux
jean honoré fragonard est quant à lui un
maître de la fin du mouvement rococo la
demande des mécènes de la cour de louis
15 l'amène à se tourner pour un temps
vers ces scènes d'amour et de volupté
auquel son nom est associé
d'autres artistes remarquables traverse
l'époque tels les portraitistes de la
cour louis michel bélot maurice quentin
de la tour et jean-marc nattier
les premiers peintres du roi sont
françois lemoine et charles antoine
coypel l'essor de la rukoko au cours de
la première moitié du siècle reflète
l'esprit de la noblesse et sa liberté
retrouvée
madame de pompadour grandes
ambassadrices de ce courant contribuer à
créer en 1740 la manufacture de sèvres
cette porcelaine tendre ornée de fleurs
délicates aux couleurs inédites comme le
plus roi ou le rose pompadour devient
rapidement la référence de l'élégance
domestique
madame de pompadour c'est la création de
la porcelaine de sèvres c'est le
renouveau de la porcelaine de france
mais c'est aussi des châteaux qu'à
l'acheter call rénové qu'elle revendait
avec beaucoup de bénéfices crécy
champs-sur-marne men à la
celle-saint-cloud que le roi lui avait
offert tout simplement un petit hôtel
particulier qui est appelé à devenir
l'elysée la résidence des présidents de
la république
c'est d'ailleurs la première fois que
l'elysée fera des bénéfices puisqu'elle
l'avait acheté 100 mille livres
elle l'a rénovée pour cent mille livres
et elle l'a revendu sept cent cinquante
mille c'est une femme d'affaires
étonnante qui va finalement gérer ça son
petit monde
une façon très intelligente et avec
beaucoup de tact mozart n'a que 6 ans
quand lors d'une tournée européenne
organisée par son père léopold il est
invité à jouer à versailles au compagnie
de sa soeur
nannerl madame de pompadour s'empressent
alors d'accueillir en son sein non les
enfants prodiges dans ses
correspondances léopold décrite ainsi la
marquise est là dans le visage et
surtout dans les yeux quelque chose
d'une impératrice romaine et les plein
d'orgueil et c'est elle qui régente tout
ici dans la juste lignée de ses
prédécesseurs baroque et de nouvelle
génération de compositeurs développe une
écriture musicale maîtrise et équilibrée
et élégante cette période qui débute
vers 10 750 1780 et perdure
jusqu'aux années 1830 et qualifier de
classique
l'apogée de ce courant révèle la
suprématie de l'école allemande
personnifié par les très illustre mozart
haydn et beethoven la trinité classique
viennoise
la marquise de pompadour affermi peu à
peu son influence à la cour elle
manoeuvre pour faire entrer au conseil
du roi des membres du parti
philosophique un nouveau monde est en
marche
armé d'une liberté de conscience
d'opinion et d'expression
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
jean
à la mort de son principal ministre le
cardinal de fleury en 1743 l'eau 15
annonce son intention de gouverner seul
il assume alors l'exercice du pouvoir au
moment où la france est sur le point
d'entrer en guerre
oui 15 n'est pas plus fainéants qu louis
xiv bien au contraire
quand on regarde les carnets de présence
de deux week-ends dans son bureau on
voit très bien que louis 15 est un homme
qui travaille qui est au travail et
qu'il n'est pas toujours en train de
prendre du plaisir
on a aussi quelques fois une tendance un
petit peu à à nourrir cette image
d'homme d'hommes axée sur les plaisirs
l'eau 15 pas bientôt pouvoir montrer
l'étendue de ses talents politiques et
stratégiques en 1740 l'empereur charles
ciss chef de la maison de habsbourg et
du saint-empire romain germanique meurt
subitement les circonstances sont alors
réunies pour qu'un conflit éclate en
europe
prix 15 n'est pas un homme belliqueux
mais cette guerre de succession
d'autriche concerne toutes les grandes
puissances et la france doit choisir son
camp charles ciss va laisser à sa fille
marie thérèse un empire énorme
évidemment ça suscite l'appétit des pays
voisins
alors la france est allié à l'espagne et
à la prusse tandis que l'autriche a
comme allié l'angleterre et les
provinces-unies frédéric ii de prusse et
la fille de charles 6 marie thérèse se
dispute bientôt la province de silésie
les britanniques rejoignent l'autriche
et la france voit là l'occasion de
briser l'alliance de l'autriche avec le
saint-empire et la prusse ou 15 remporte
une série de victoires importantes
la bataille de fontenoy le 11 mai 10 745
reste dans les mémoires comme l'une des
grandes victoires françaises décisive
contre les britanniques
tu
[Musique]
en 1748 la france occupe l'ensemble des
pays bas autrichiens et semble être en
voie d'accomplir son rêve
l'extension de sa frontière nord-est
jusqu'au ras madame de pompadour a joué
un rôle important dans les décisions du
roi militairement puisque et la
provoquer l'alliance du roi avec la
prusse contre l'autriche bien sûr et à
partir de ce moment là la france ne
s'étant pas comment dirais-je comporter
en
patry victorieuse et bien louis 15
commence d'être un petit peu décrié par
le citoyen la guerre de succession
d'autriche va être terrible et va se
terminer en 1748 par le traité d'aix la
chapelle
et c'est une catastrophe pour la france
parce que nous sommes obligés de rendre
un certain nombre de territoires à
l'autriche
et c'est d'ailleurs là une des
explications du début de louis 15 le mal
aimé
le traité d'aix la chapelle signé le 28
octobre 1748 marque la victoire des
coalisés mais ne permet pas à la france
de conserver les territoires conquis
dans le sud des pays bas du français
opprimés par les taxes et la disette
sont déçus il raille le roi louis 15 par
l'expression bête comme la paix mais ce
traité qui met un terme à la guerre de
succession d'autriche n'était en réalité
qu'une trêve il va y avoir des pertes
humaines très importante un roi qui ne
s'occupe pas de sa population mais quand
on gagne le peuple peut le tolérer quand
on perd il ne le tolère pas et donc 7,7
cette image que l'on va avoir de louis
case va s'effriter dans le temps à cause
des pertes militaires
[Musique]
bien que ses origines roturières soir
raillé par l'aristocratie la marquise de
pompadour tisse une véritable influence
à la cour et dans l'esprit du roi
les courtisans se pressent dans ses
appartements où elle installe un
protocole digne d'une reine elle quitte
peu à peu son rôle de maîtresse pour
devenir la confidente et la conseillère
essentiel du roi elle joue alors de son
pouvoir pour dispenser faveurs et
disgrâces soutient louis 15 dans ses
décisions et participe aux plus hautes
manoeuvre politique
après la guerre de succession d'autriche
la france est ruinée afin de combler le
déficit budgétaire
louis 15 as le malheur d'approuver sur
les conseils de la marquise
l'instauration d'un impôt sur le revenu
qui s'applique aussi aux classes
privilégiées
elle va proposer à louis 15 d'instaurer
le 20e le 20e était un impôt pour tous
un impôt qui était à la fois point la
noblesse et à la fois pour les religieux
dont imaginez-vous c'est la catastrophe
en france qui est cette femme qui est
cette bourgeoise qui vient imposer la
totalité de la population
on ne peut le souffrir et finalement
madame de pompadour sera obligé de faire
demi tour et souvent politique madame de
pompadour sera obligé de faire demi tour
le 15 heures à nos positions violentes
des privilégiés des parlementaires
attise le feu des mécontentements et
font bloc contre toutes les mesures
visant à réformer le système de l'impôt
ou à affaiblir les privilèges les
parlements usent de leur droit de
remontrances pour bloquer l'exécution du
pouvoir royal
le rendant ainsi fort fébrile
la cabale contre la poisson et le mal
aimé et lançait des libelles injurieux
circule contre la marquise ses pamphlets
déchaîné qu'on appelle poissonnade
incitent à la haine et au meurtre des
grands seigneurs sa vie lisse et
financier s'enrichissent tous les
poissons s'agrandisse c'est lauren des
vauriens week-end ne laisse pas l'image
d'un homme qui s'occupe particulièrement
de son peuple
c'est un homme qui est vieux et qui
prend toujours des maîtresses jeunes et
qu'ils dépensent beaucoup l'argent de
l'état et ça c'est quelque chose qui ne
va pas non plus être tolérée dans les
différents dans les différentes parties
du règne aura des famines et le week end
c'est pas réagir
le royaume est au bord de la guerre
civile quand robert francois damiens
manque d' assassiner le roi le 5 janvier
1757 louis cainne survie mais il sombre
dans une humeur noire
le garde des sceaux machault
d'arnouville recommande alors au
souverain d'éloigner sa très impopulaire
maîtresse mais c'est l'homme d'état qui
disparaît dans les limbes de la disgrâce
sur cet échiquier politique extrêmement
mouvant la pompadour a su elle se rendre
indispensable au roi elle entraîne ainsi
à la tête de l'état étienne françois de
choiseul habile politique qui va devenir
l'homme le plus puissant du royaume on a
souvent parlé de l' influence politique
de madame de pompadour pas en bien
d'ailleurs
c'est vrai que c'est elle qui
responsable de l'avènement de choiseul à
l'état mais elle n'a pas fait et défait
les ministres comme on l'a si souvent
dit non madame de pompadour est une
femme qui prend des décisions souvent
très juste qui va tirer un petit peu les
ficelles mais pas autant que cela au
niveau politique
[Musique]
les luttes de pouvoir au sommet de
l'état les velléités d'indépendance des
parlements le mécontentement populaire
et la montée des forces anti monarchique
menace la stabilité de la couronne mais
2756 un autre conflit se dessine cette
fois à l'échelle mondiale
[Musique]
après avoir conclu la paix avec
l'autriche
le roi veut que son royaume connaissent
enfin la paix la france se bâtit donc un
empire dans les indes et au nouveau
monde et ne cherche plus à s'emparer des
territoires de ses voisins pourtant en
1755 l'angleterre attaque la france des
camps sont un conflit colonial au même
moment au sein de la vieille europe
l'impératrice marie thérèse d'autriche
regarde vers la précieuse silésie
qu'elle veut reconquérir
mais frédéric ii de prusse s'avère être
un puissant ennemi marie thérèse envoie
donc son ambassadeur courtiser la
marquise de pompadour et lui souffler
qu'un rapprochement entre bobo et
habsbourg est possible
des négociations secrètes commence mais
louis 15 se montre d'abord réticent
la trahison de frédéric dit d'eux qu'ils
s'allient aux anglais en 1756 le décide
à se rapprocher de marie thérèse pour
signer un accord défensif d'assistance
mutuelle
les alliances sont renversés
à la cour de france cette nouvelle
entente est très critiquée on accuse la
marquise de s'être laissé flatté par
l'impératrice qui l'appelle ma cousine
alors la guerre de sept ans arrive
quelques années après la guerre de
succession d'autriche c'est la
conséquence est évidente et c'est une
manière de véritablement de première
guerre mondiale avant l'heure parce que
il ya l'étape pays d'europe et voir
d'amérique c'est à dire du nouveau monde
qui sont en guerre dans cette guerre qui
va durer sept ans frédéric de lance les
hostilités en envahissant la saxe sans
déclaration de guerre officiel la guerre
de sept ans voit des ennemis séculaires
france autriche suède et russie
s'opposait à l'angleterre dans un
conflit qui s'étend sur trois continents
c'est en raison de son caractère global
qu'on la considère parfois comme la
toute première guerre mondiale
on arrive avec louis 15 dans une période
qui ressemble un peu à la période
contemporaine avec d une europe
extrêmement fragile
des guerres intra-européennes très
nombreuses et surtout une une
mondialisation parce que nous nous
affrontons pour la première fois très
durement avec les anglais et les
espagnols en amérique pour garder nos
possessions d'amérique nous nous battons
en inde le roi de prusse anéanti les
espoirs de la coalition en remportant
l'éclatante victoire de rothbach le 5
novembre 1757
le nouveau secrétaire britannique de la
guerre william pitt met en place une
stratégie audacieuse et parvient à
expulser les français d'amérique du nord
la pompadour refuse de décevoir ses
alliés à impériale marie thérèse
d'autriche et elisabeth 1ère de russie
et les hostilités se poursuivent entre
frédéric ii est celle qu'ils surnomment
les trois illustrissime la mort
de l'impératrice de russie en janvier
1762 change la donne
son successeur pierre iii est un fervent
admirateur de frédéric deux se désengage
de la coalition et signent la paix avec
la prusse la france évidemment ne se
sortira pas brillamment puisque les
anglais vont nous pas nous anéantir et
l'asthme et récupérer toutes les
colonies ou presque que nous avions au
nouveau monde et c'est à la suite aussi
de sa queue eh oui que la langue
française qui était la langue la plus
parlée au monde va devenir va être
écrasé par la langue anglaise puisque
les anglais s'installe un peu partout là
où nous avions de colo né en 1763 la
quasi-totalité de l'empiré colonial
français en inde et en amérique revient
à l'angleterre
ruiné et humilié la france n'a plus
d'autre choix que de signer le
désastreux traité de paris le 10 février
1763 par lequel elles renoncent à ces
colonies d'amérique du nord pour
récupérer la martinique la guadeloupe
est simplissime
ces précieuses îles à sucre constitue le
coeur du très prolifique commerce
triangulaire français nantes est le
premier port négrier du royaume au
xviiie siècle on dénombre 1300 bateau
qui transporte environ 1,1 million
d'esclaves
malgré l'esprit des lumières beaucoup
d'intellectuels possède des terres
antillaises ou comme voltaire figure au
rang des actionnaires de négriers un
navire de 250 tonnes peut transporter
500 esclaves qui avant d'être vendus
dans les colonies sont attachés et
entassés dans la cale durant les
soixante six jours que dure le terrible
passage du milieu celui de l'agent tic
[Musique]
après la guerre de sept ans les pertes
territoriale ne font qu'amplifier le
mécontentement le siècle des lumières a
appris au peuple à penser par lui-même
et la parole devient sa nouvelle arme
ban ki avocat marchand écrivain acteur
artisan et artiste commence à diffuser
plus largement leur opinion
les critiques fustige un gouvernement
faible et corrompue et s'attaque aux
détenteurs de privilèges l'autorité
royale est mise à mal et le roi est
désacralisé au conflit politique
s'ajoute un affrontement religieux qui
destitue l'ordre jésuites en france et
révèle que l'unité spirituelle du
royaume est bel et bien rompue ya une
phrase terrible de l'historien jules
michelet qui devait après voltaire et
rousseau
de toute façon la révolution était fait
c'est à dire que j'ai vu quelque chose
qui s'étaient débloquées dans les
esprits il y avait eu des livres qui
s'était beaucoup vendu on peut ajouter
aussi monté ce que cette théorie des
pouvoirs qui plus du tout les théories
nous éloigne complètement de la
monarchie médiévale son analyse de la
monarchie constitutionnelle britannique
est vraiment à partir de là on était on
est dans quelque chose d'assez près
révolutionnaires sont les bourgeois qui
vont faire évoluer les idées jeanne
antoinette poisson n'est-elle pas
bourgeoise et c'est tout ce mouvement
bourgeois qui depuis des années près à
la noblesse qui depuis des années ne
peut pas jouir de pouvoir alors même
qu'elles financent et bien va se
retourner sous louis 15 vers cette
noblesse et tout doucement commencé à
prendre du pouvoir
la position affirmée de la classe
bourgeoise la montée de la dépendance
des parlements et la désunion
religieuses appelle à des mutations qui
oxyde peu à peu les fondements mêmes de
la monarchie
au 15 et bouleversé par la mort de sa
douce amie madame de pompadour qu'il
l'ait s'éteindre à versailles le 15
avril 17 164 alors que le protocole
interdit la marquise rend l'âme à 6 et
fier refusant de quitter son fauteuil
tout comme le trône de substitution où
elle s'est imposée pendant près de 20
ans
[Musique]
choiseul l'ami de la pompadour dirige à
présent la politique de la france en
véritable vice-roi leduc rattache la
lorraine royaume en 1766 achète la corse
à la république de gênes en 1768
réorganise l'armée et la marine et crée
le port militaire de lorient mais son
obsession
reste que la france redevienne une
grande puissance coloniale en 1770 leroy
qui ne veut pas d'une autre guerre est
irritée d'apprendre que son ministre
projette de défendre l'espagne contre
l'angleterre dans un conflit au sujet
des îles falklands choiseul poursuit
néanmoins sa propre stratégie dans le
but de restaurer la puissance française
les documents révèlent qu'il se sert
d'un réseau d'espions pour mener des
négociations secrètes
tout cela en vain comme le veut le jeu
de cour et évincé par madame du barry
nouvelles favorites royales en titre
après la mort de la pompadour pendant le
règne de jouy 15 les parlements
s'agitent les parlements gigote un peu
le un des ministres louis 15 qui appelle
monsieur de maupeou essaye de les brimer
de les exilés donc le parlement commence
à vouloir se manifester vigoureusement
ce qui annonce évidemment les temps plus
chaud par la suite dans les dernières
années du règne de louis 15
le message est clair et fort le pays a
besoin de réformes politiques
religieuses et économiques radicales
le duc d'aiguillon le chancelier de
maupeou et l'abbé été ré engagé en vain
une politique de répression contre les
parlementaires pour restaurer l'autorité
du roi on tente de nouveau d'imposer les
classes privilégiées ou exemptés de
taxes mais le système va perdurer sans
connaître aucune réforme ou jusqu'à la
révolution française la révolution
française est une révolution de
bourgeois ce n'est pas une révolution
populaire la révolution française
si on veut l'expliquer il faut remonter
au règne de louis xiv pour bien la
comprendre
car ce n'est pas si vous voulez hein
force avec une simple signature à au
bout d'une page
la révolution française c'est un énorme
mouvement qui a des explications de
plusieurs décennies avec un peuple
opprimé depuis des décennies avec des
gens qui veulent évoluer depuis des
décennies et surtout avec une
bourgeoisie qui n'attend qu'une chose
c'est de renverser la noblesse et de
prendre le pouvoir
[Musique]
après l'absolutisme du roi soleil
l'avènement de louis 15 a permis à
l'espoir de remettre le surnom
affectueux de bien aimer décerné au
début de son règne quand il était beau
jeune et que le pays vivait en paix
s'érode en même temps que la confiance
de son peuple
ce souverain qui n'était pas destiné à
régner a certainement manqué de
confiance et de fermeté sa fidèle et
sincère amie madame de pompadour est
resté à ses côtés pour le soutenir dans
toutes ses décisions
considérée comme une des femmes les plus
influentes de l'histoire de france elle
a su résister à de nombreux ennemis et
au plus violente qu'à bâle dirigée
contre sa personne et celle du roi
marquises des arts est immense mais
celle elle a largement contribué au
développement culturel et au rayonnement
artistique de la france louis 15 a régné
pendant une période de changement
radical des idées politiques sociales et
intellectuelles l'aube d'une société
nouvelle se dessine le monde évolue et
réclament une nouvelle forme de pouvoir
qui déstabilise les fondements mêmes de
la société d'ancien régime
cinquante neuf années de règne parsemez
de guerre inutile de défaite trop
nombreuses
allier une gouvernance maladroite et à
la montée des idées progressistes des
lumières ont profondément atteint le
prestige de la couronne louis 15 lègue à
son petit fils louis saez une france qui
a perdu sa suprématie sur le théâtre
européen alors que l'angleterre
l'autriche et la russie sont de plus en
plus puissantes
le déclin de l'autorité royale va
bientôt faire le lit de la révolution
française et donner raison à ces
quelques mots prophétiques lancé par
voltaire les français ne sont pas faits
pour la liberté
il en abuse ray